This episode of DNews is brought to you by
the BuyPower Card from Capital One.
Every purchase brings you closer to a new
Chevrolet, Buick, GMC or Cadillac vehicle.
What makes someone a risk-taker?
And is it embedded in our personalities - or
is something we can change over time?
Hey guys, Tara here for Dnews - and I gotta
say, it’s pretty amazing just how different
and complex people can be.
When we think about someone’s personality,
for example we’re usually evaluating them
on a scale of certain aspects: humor, compassion,
outgoingness - but what about adventurousness?
What is it about our biology, that makes some
of us risk takers - and some of us not?
It turns out, like most things in life - the
answer isn’t black or white.
It’s more like, a rainbow of colors that
are constantly changing, for each new phase
of life we enter.
In reality, everyone has different reasons
for why they choose to take risks - so people
who are cautious in some areas, may actually
embrace taking risks in others.
Elke Weber is a psychologist and business
professor at Columbia University, who developed
the "domain-specific risk propensity" model.
It theorizes that everyone has a unique risk
propensity, spread out among five categories:
financial, health/safety, recreational, ethical,
and social.
And your willingness to take risks, she says,
can vary widely from one category to the next.
It’s the gender divide, though, that really
explains the underlying reason for risk-taking.
Obviously there are exceptions, but generally
speaking, men tend to take more risks than
women - and especially financial and recreational
risks.
It harkens back to a “culture of honor,”
where men feel like they need to defend themselves
and assert their masculinity, in order to
protect their honor.
And taking risks, is a big part of that.
But according to Andreas Wilke, an expert
on risk-taking and decision-making, there’s
also a sexual aspect to it.
Because men have more intra-sexual competition
than women do for sex, they feel the need
to advertise their sexual fitness through
daring exploits.
So “if you compare the behavior of a single
adolescent male,” he says, “with his behavior
when women are watching, you can see how the
risk increases.”
Sure enough, people - and especially men - tend
to become less risk-seeking as they get older,
and as they enter into stable relationships.
But that’s not to say that women aren’t
risk-takers either.
In fact, studies have consistently shown that
women tend to take more social risks than
men.
Things like moving to a new city, wearing
unconventional clothes, changing careers later
in life, or expressing unpopular opinions
during a business meeting.
What’s especially interesting, is other
research showing that experiencing discrimination
or rejection leads people to take more chances.
So if women feel as though they’re operating
under a patriarchal society, it makes sense
that they might take even more social risks,
as a way of tacitly fighting back.
Of course, out of all the risks you should
take - financial ones probably aren’t the
best idea.
Fortunately, the BuyPower Card from Capital
One offers no risks - and tons of rewards.
With the BuyPower Card, you’ll get 5% Earnings
on your first $5,000 in purchases every year,
and unlimited 2% Earnings after that.
Every purchase can be applied towards a new
Chevrolet, Buick, GMC or Cadillac vehicle.
Your earnings never expire, and there is absolutely
no limit on the amount you can earn or redeem.
In the meantime, let us know in the comments
below - if you consider yourself to be a risk-taker.
That’s it for me, but as always - thank
you guys for watching!
This episode of DNews was brought to you by
the BuyPower Card from Capital One.
Every purchase brings you closer to a new
Chevrolet, Buick, GMC or Cadillac vehicle.